JONAH JONES: Hey everyone.
Thanks for coming.
Today we're going to talk about
the process of redesigning
Google Maps.
My name's Jonah.
I've been working as a designer
at Google for seven years now.
ANNETTE LEONG: Hello everyone.
My name is Annette.
I'm also a designer
on Google Maps.
I've been at Google
for 2 and 1/2 years.
In the new Maps I designed
the overall framework
and image browsing experience.
JONAH JONES: And I led
the overall redesign.
So Google Maps was
launched back in 2005.
And this time last year, we
announced the new Google Maps.
And this was the biggest
redesign we'd ever done.
Over the last year we've
made a ton of changes.
We had a long preview period.
And now this is the new
default experience for Maps.
So there are some pretty major
changes that have taken place.
The map is now dynamic
and full screen
and it adapts to every
single one of your clicks.
And the imagery is also
fully immersive in 3D.
But as you can imagine,
redesigning a product used
by a billion people is
quite a daunting task.
And we wanted to share
a little bit of insight
into what our process was,
so that you can design
your apps to be ready for
a billion users as well.
And we thought about
what this entailed.
And we realized
that it basically
boils down to three key lessons.
The first is to think big.
So that you don't get
trapped incrementalism.
The second is to
question everything,
because sometimes
your assumptions
can be holding you back.
And the third lesson is
to listen to your users,
because even if you think
big and question everything,
you're not going to be
right about everything.
So let's jump into the first
lesson, which is to think big.
We started with
an audacious goal,
which is that we wanted
to redefine expectations
of online maps.
And if you look at what we
had with the previous maps,
we'd added so many
features over the years
that the old user
interface was starting
to get really, really cluttered.
And every new
feature we added was
making it harder to
find that new feature
and the old features too.
We'd added thousands
of businesses.
We'd added thousands of
miles of Street View.
And we'd also added
further ways of transport,
so it's not just about driving.
It can be about walking
or public transit.
On a technology
side as well, Ajax
was the big innovation
back in 2005
that let people smoothly
scroll and zoom the map.
But nowadays, there are
more recent technologies
like HTML5 and WebGL that
let people do vector graphics
directly within a web browser.
And consumer expectations
had changed too.
The arrival of mobile
had brought new paradigms
for touch-based user interfaces.
But even more
fundamentally than that,
we felt the existing mapping
products were basically
just taking this old
scanned map and sprinkling
a few pins on top and adding
a search box at the top.
And we thought surely
we can do better
with dynamic digital maps.
So we went back to
the drawing board.
And we thought how would Maps
be if we reinvented it today,
using all of the great data
that we have as a foundation
and everything that we've
learned over those last seven
years.
And we came up with
this vision that we
called "The Future of Maps."
And we created this
short video that we
shipped around the company.
And this was really,
really good to get people
on the same page about
where our vision was,
and where we were headed, and
where our big thinking was
going.
And actually it's
quite interesting.
Looking at this video,
there's a lot of the concepts
that we had there made it
through into the final product.
So here you see we have
a beautiful new set
of rich dynamic
bright map tiles.
And this is Lausanne
in Switzerland.
And what happens now is we
click on a transit station.
And suddenly the map shifts.
And dynamically becomes all
about the transit network.
Later in the video
we do a search.
And now we can see
that the search results
are the primary focused thing.
And they're labeled too.
And then toward the end of
the video, we zoom in further.
And amongst all of the
regular points of interest,
we see the places that I've
been to, and I've rated.
And the places that my friends
have been to and rated as well.
So this is a map built for you.
Over to Annette.
ANNETTE LEONG: While the concept
video focused on the map tiles,
it was a challenge to come
up with a framework that
could really support and
highlight the maps itself.
And yet be fully
functional and easy to use.
We wanted to think big.
We wanted to be able to
explore quickly and capture
all possibilities.
And wireframes and sketches
were great for that.
We made hundreds of
wireframes and sketches
to generate ideas
and to [INAUDIBLE]
and also lay out variations.
This method let us go broad.
Then, from a subset of these
wireframes and sketches,
we went steep.
We started filling in with
the right typography, colors,
and visual elements to
create higher fidelity marks.
The look and feel of
the product started
to really come together.
As we generated more
and more of these marks,
it can be hard to keep track
of what's the latest version.
It's like an engineer
constantly asked you
where can I find
the latest file?
So we needed a better
way to organize them.
As you may know,
when engineers want
to show progress of
their latest code,
they create a build to test how
well the code in the biggest
system.
So we did the same for design.
We created a design build,
where we put in all the latest
designs from individual
designers into a single place.
To keep things simple
and easy to digest,
we focused on a
few key scenarios.
Like finding a restaurant,
getting directions,
and browsing imagery.
This let the designers,
PMs, engineers, and everyone
in the company to see
where we were headed.
JONAH JONES: So it's really
important to think big.
But if you want
to think big, you
have to be willing to
question everything.
So you could argue if it
ain't broke, don't fix it.
This seems fairly reasonable.
But it turns out
this isn't really
the case with technology.
As you saw before, adding
more and more features
meant that we couldn't
stay still anymore.
But also the world is changing.
So by staying still, you're
basically moving backward.
So I want to give you
a couple of examples
of where we were questioning
things as we were redesigning
different parts of the system.
And the first is around
the map tiles themselves.
So this is how the map
tiles used to look,
when you were looking
at a world view.
And you can see
here that we've got
some countries and some
states and obviously the land
masses and stuff.
But we realized
that actually this
isn't answering
all the questions
that our users might have.
Like why are people going
to a map at this zoom level?
Well first of all,
you can't really
differentiate between the cities
and the states in the US there.
You can't really see
where the mountains are.
You can't see where the forests
are, and where the deserts are.
This map isn't really doing
everything that it needs to.
So when we did the redesign, we
answered all these questions.
Now you can clearly
see the difference
between countries and states.
We've got elevation
data, so that you
can see where the
mountain ranges are.
And we have vegetation
data too, so you
can see the lush green areas and
the more barren orange areas.
And plus also, we used a new
brighter, more vibrant color
palette, so this feels
much more on brand
than how it did before.
The same is true at
deeper zoom levels, too.
This is the map of how San
Francisco used to look.
And you can see here our
heritage, that basically we
just used to be a road map.
But that's really
all you can see here.
But even the roads, they're
kind of overwhelming.
They're really, really fat.
And this orange highlight
color and the yellow
is being used way too much
and not sparingly enough.
And you also can't see all
of the other information
that people care about
at this zoom level.
You can't see the neighborhoods.
You can't see public transit.
You can't see where
the parks are.
So we really want to
redesign this, too.
So this new design answers
all of the questions
that people need to know
about from a city level too.
You can still see the road
hierarchy very clearly,
but it's cleaner.
You can now see the
neighborhoods too.
You can see the businesses,
the points of interest.
You can see the
transit information.
You can see all of this stuff.
Now another example
is around this concept
of a map of a place.
So let's imagine that
tomorrow after I/O
we're all going to
go for a picnic.
And we're going to meet
in the Pullens Gardens.
And I share this map with you.
Now on first glance, this
map looks fairly reasonable.
But if you look
closer, this really
isn't the best map that
I could have given you.
So for a start, there's
a ton of labels on here
that you really don't
need to know about.
And some of the labels you
wish were there are missing.
So if you look at the Pullens
Gardens in the middle,
you can see Penton
Place bordering it.
But you can't see the names
of those other two streets.
So surely we can do
better than this.
So we took inspiration
from the kind of map
that you might draw on
the back of a napkin,
if you were telling your friend
how to get to this place.
In that kind of map,
people will only
show the most
important information.
You can see here
that all we're doing
is we're highlighting the
major roads that are landmarks
and the roads that are nearby
and bordering this place.
These are the roads that
you need to know about
to get to this place,
and the other ones
are much less important.
We even developed a
pretty snazzy algorithm
to approximate
this kind of data,
where we look at anonymized
logs of all of the directions
that anyone has ever
got to this place.
And we look at the
most popular ones.
And if you're interested
on how this works,
we get a Tech Talk last year
at I/O that's available online,
that goes into more depth.
But so here we go.
We've got these roads.
We've got the ones
that are important.
But now we have to
decide how we're
going to render
these on the map.
So the first idea
we tried was we
thought, OK, let's take
these important roads.
And we're going to
visually lift these up.
And make them very prominent.
And all of the other
roads we're going to let
sink back into the background.
And this kind of
conceptually works.
You can see that
it's a little bit
like that napkin map we had.
But there's one
really big problem
with this, which
is that we've lost
the sense of road hierarchy.
You can now know longer
tell the difference
between the big major
arterial roads and the more
minor, local roads.
So we had to come up with a
solution that didn't interfere
with the fundamental
road network.
So back to the drawing board.
We try another version.
And we thought what if
all of the roads are grey.
And we can convey the
network using widths instead.
And what we'll do is we'll
light up these important roads.
And this actually looks pretty
cool, even on the [INAUDIBLE],
you can kind of see
the concept there.
But what happened when we
built this thing is as you're
clicking around,
the roads changing
was just far too
visually jarring.
It created much
too much prominence
for what the feature deserved.
So, threw that
idea away as well.
And we came up with
this other idea.
We thought, well, the
way the algorithm works
is it's basically
taking directions.
So why don't we just draw
these tiny little arrows,
because it's all about
getting directions
from the north, the south,
and the east, and the west.
This seems like a
cool idea, right?
But then we put this
in front of people.
And this didn't work
too well either.
We were too close
to the algorithm.
And it turned out that
the users were confused
between real sets of directions
and these weird little blue
arrows we were
drawing everywhere.
But the good thing about
all of these explorations
was that we learned something.
So that let us finally
come up with the end design
that we did.
This answers all
of the problems.
Now the most important
roads are brighter
and they're highlighted.
They're labeled as well.
You can see that those roads
next to Pullens Gardens that
weren't labeled before,
are-- Crampton Street,
Iliffe Street, Amelia Street.
And the change is actually
quite subtle as well.
Because the other
roads are still there,
but they've just sunk into
the background a little bit
and the most important
roads have lifted slightly,
this is not such
a dramatic change
as you go and click
around the map.
It subtly draws people's
eye, without being
a massive headline feature.
To give you another example
around search results.
So here, this is a search
for bars in Sydney.
And there's something
quite interesting
going on with this map too.
Which is that we
have a lot of places
that are labeled on the
map, but none of these
are the places that
you've asked for.
These are all the generic
things that were left on the map
from before.
Sushi Train, Oxford Vintage
Cellars, Darlinghurst.
And the very thing that you're
interested in-- the bars--
they're not labeled.
They're the only
thing we don't label.
This is crazy.
So we've just got
these red pins.
And there's a letter, and you
have to cross reference it.
And part of this was
because we didn't
use to be able to
dynamically render labels,
but now we could.
So we thought OK, we can
definitely do better than this.
So here's what we first tried.
We thought, well
the search results,
they're conceptually the
same as a landmark really.
They're just a thing that we're
going to highlight on the map.
So why don't we just draw
them the same as a landmark.
And we'll just draw a little
red circle around them
to highlight them.
But this had problems, which
is that it looked kind of messy
as you started zooming out.
But even more fundamentally,
you couldn't tell the difference
between the most relevant search
results and the search results.
So it could get a
bit overwhelming.
So how are we going
to solve that.
We thought OK, what we can
do is we can put the star
ratings directly on the map.
This seems like a good idea.
But actually, here
you can see this
isn't working so well, either.
The star ratings
and the red dots
are kind of competing
with each other,
and the whole thing
looks a bit overwhelming.
And it also turns out that star
ratings are not the best way
to differentiate between places.
Because all the top places tend
to be about four stars anyway.
So what's a more human
way of doing this?
We thought aha.
What we could do is we
could take the top places.
And we could differentiate them
with some human readable text.
So you can see
here that Esan Thai
is known for its
pineapple fried rice.
But Aroy Thai is known
for the Pad Thai.
Now this seemed like
a strong concept.
But even this version
was lacking as well.
Because typographically,
you couldn't really
tell the difference between the
top and the secondary research
results.
And also we've lost some
of the key information.
You can no longer now see what
type of business each of these
are.
We don't have the
knife and fork anymore.
So with the learnings from
all of these different
explorations, we finally
came up with something
that really worked.
We used a bright red color to
indicate the search results.
And now they're
conceptually very similar
than the landmarks,
which are much more set
in the background.
You can tell the
difference between the top
and the secondary
results through size.
And we've still got this very
useful text string, which
says herb marinated
chicken, or whatever.
So we put this first
in front of users.
And we were super
excited to see how
their reaction was going to be.
We expected them
to be blown away.
Wow.
You've labeled search
results on the map.
This is awesome.
No one's ever done this before.
And what actually happened
was nobody noticed.
And we realized that
that's actually OK.
Because of course the
search results are labeled.
Weren't you doing that before?
People instantly forgot that
we didn't used to do that.
And it's a reminder that
sometimes the best design--
people won't even notice it.
It will just work
and get out the way.
So Annette's going
to give you a couple
more details around
place details.
ANNETTE LEONG: Similar
to the napkin map
design and the search results
and signposts that Jonah gave,
we are still questioned a
lot on the place details.
In the old maps, when
you searched for bars,
there's a list of results
in the left-hand panel
and also on the map.
When you click on
the result, whether
from the left-hand
panel or on the map,
there was this
informational window
that appeared on the map.
We asked ourselves, why does
this informational window
have to be that big and
cover so much of the map?
And secondly, why is the
information showing twice?
The same information is
showing in the left-hand panel
and also in the
informational window.
The more we question
the UI, the more
we can get a better sense of
how we can improve upon it.
We tried a version, what
if we took away all the UI
and had the search
box only appear
when you click on a place.
It didn't really work well,
because you expect the search
box to be at a
persistent location.
So you click on the
place and it shows up
at a different location.
It's a style strange.
So we ditched the idea
and tried another version.
What if we want to
show more of the map?
So we show the text on the
transparent background.
This also didn't really work
well, because as you can see,
the text can be hard to read
against different backgrounds.
And also, the actions
that you may need,
like getting directions
and saving a place,
are hidden with
another click away.
What if we try a version
that the text radiated
from the place you clicked.
Visually it looked cool
and somewhat interesting.
But it also opened up
another can of worms.
Like the space limitations
and also legibility.
And the more we questioned
all these explorations,
we learned from them.
So finally, we landed on
this version where the text--
the information about
the place is always
showing in the upper left
corner in a predictable way.
And this information
box can be minimized
when you want to
see more of the map.
Sometimes the problems
can be obvious,
but the right
solution might not be.
It takes questioning everything,
exploring everything,
to get to a much simpler design.
JONAH JONES: OK.
So the final lesson is
that it's really important
to listen to your users.
And there's a bunch of
different ways you can do this.
You could run usability studies.
You can study your user metrics.
You can directly
solicit user feedback.
Or you can run an
internal dogfood.
Dogfood is the idea that
you eat your own dogfood.
So you test the app internally,
before you release it
into the wild, to
the general public.
But it's important that
you do all of these
and don't just focus on one.
I'm going to give you
a couple of examples
of why this is important.
So the first is around speed.
So when we first
launched the new Maps,
we heard some users
were giving us
feedback that we needed
to make it faster.
And we thought, this
is kind of interesting.
Because when we
looked at our logs,
average speed was-- the new Maps
was faster than the old Maps.
But it turns out that
wasn't the whole picture.
It turns out the for
people with fast computers
and fast network
connections, the new Maps
was indeed significantly faster.
For people with
average computers
and average connections, the new
Maps was a bit faster or about
the same.
But for people with slow
computers or slow internet
connections, the
new Maps was slower.
That's why people
were saying this.
This is a problem.
They were kind of seeing
something like this.
They were seeing this
extended loading screen.
And they were waiting
for that to load.
Oh, man.
This is so slow, come
on, come on, come on.
OK, it's loaded.
And so we sent our crack
team of engineers on this.
And they worked night and day.
And they managed to
get the loading speed
down to half of
what it used to be.
And this was pretty amazing,
but it's still not fast enough.
So this needed a bit of
a more creative solution.
And we realized that people
tend to do one of two things
when they first
load up Google Maps.
Number one is that
they just kind of stare
at the map tiles for one
or two or three seconds.
Just to get a sense
of orientation.
And number two
was if they're not
doing that, they tend
to go to the search box
and just start typing.
So we thought, what if
we could be smarter.
What if-- is this
the new loading
sequence or the old one.
It's the new one.
OK.
What if we could load the map
tiles first, in a static way.
So they're not the
normal 3D ones.
These are just a
quick set of map tiles
that we can load immediately.
This gives all those
people who just
want to look at
the map something
to do much, much quicker.
And what if we could
enable the search box,
so that people can
type into that.
Now, in a much, much
quicker amount of time,
we're showing the map and
we're letting people type
into the search box.
And by the time they're
done doing that stuff,
the rest of the map is loaded.
So this is a sign that real
speed is very, very important.
But the perceived speed can
be very important as well.
The number of people who are
dissatisfied with the speed
went down dramatically
after we did this change.
There's a second example too.
And this is what happens
when you click on a place,
and then we load
this new map that's
built for this place
with the new roads.
And there's actually
quite a few things
going on here that
you'll notice.
So the first thing is
that when we click,
we have to wait for
200 milliseconds
to differentiate between
if this is a click, which
is to select something, or
a double click to zoom in.
And there's nothing, really,
you can do about this.
But if you just wait,
it will feel slow.
So what we do is we immediately
do a little ripple event that
responds to the first click.
And after that 200
milliseconds time out,
that's when we begin to
lift the pen up in the air.
So this now feels immediately
much more responsive.
The second thing that happens
is that the pin jumps up
into the air and then lands.
And as it lands, the map
responds and updates.
And this is done because as
soon as we know that there's
been a click, we have to
go back to the server,
figure out what all these roads
are that we need to highlight,
come back again to the
client, and then re-render
these new map tiles.
And had we waited to do
that, before showing the pin,
that would feel laggy.
But lad we shown
the pin immediately,
and then the map tiles had
updated sometime later,
that would also feel laggy.
So this solution lets
us begin the animation.
Everyone's watching
that, they're distracted,
and then it lands.
And then the map tiles update.
And this not only
hides the loading,
but it also adds personality
and character to the map.
So we managed to kill two
birds with one stone here.
Annette's going to
give you some more
examples around Street View.
ANNETTE LEONG: Imagery was
one of the major features
in the redesign.
We wanted to make discovering
images much more easier.
In the old maps, there was
this to little yellow guy
that we called Pegman, where
you have to click the Pegman
and jerk him to the map, in
order to see Street View.
And some people did
not discover that.
So in the redesign, we wanted
to put the images up front.
So we replaced the Pegman
with a sequence of images
at the bottom.
We tested this design
in our internal dogfood.
We were rather surprised that
one of the comments we got
was that, where did
you put Street View.
So in this design,
we thought that we
had a clean and organized
way to organize everything.
Information is at the top, and
the images are at the bottom.
But that wasn't what users saw.
When the users saw the
information at the top,
they were questioning
where was Street View.
And they saw the
images at the bottom,
and they questioned
what those were.
In order to match the
user's mental model better,
we changed our design.
We grouped the information and
images together in one place.
And users can still see
images about the neighborhood
by opening the imagery
cursor at the bottom.
Finally, people are able to
get into Street View more
intuitively.
Problem solved.
But there was another problem.
In our usability study,
we noticed that once
people got into Street
View they actually
did not move around much.
They actually were missing
out on all the fun.
What a shame.
How could we fix it?
So we looked again, we
looked into our old UI.
There was this
circular highlight
that followed the
cursor, supposed
to indicate that you
could click and move.
But some people
did not get that.
We tried a bunch of
designs, and finally we
made two small but
important changes.
One, we changed the
cursor from an arrow
to a hand with a
pointing finger.
Now people understand that
they can click to proceed.
Secondly, we added an arrow
inside the circle highlight.
Now people understand
that when they click
they will also moved
toward that direction.
This all leads to some
really great news.
Our Street View usage
was up three times,
according to our metrics.
In the meantime, something
strange was happening.
People were still asking
to bring back Pegman.
We were wondering why.
Our Street View usage
was up three times.
Why are people still
asking to bring Pegman?
So we looked into it further.
Turned out there's a
group of users like Anita,
who thinks of a place first.
So she would search and see
Street View, she is happy.
This explains why
the new design was
successful to help Anita to
discover images much easier.
Which also explains why our
usage was up three times.
There's another group
of users like Susannah,
who thinks of Street View first.
So she did not search.
And she's not seeing any images.
Nor the Pegman like
in the old maps.
She is stuck.
So we decided to
bring Pegman back.
And now Pegman is happier,
because he's living closer
to the imagery carousel.
And our users like Anita and
Susannah are happier too.
Sometimes when you
design a product,
it may not be matching how
your users use your product.
You may have to listen carefully
and observe carefully, in order
to improve your design further.
Finally, it's really important
to close the feedback loop.
During our preview period,
we received tons of feedback
from our users.
As soon as we fixed an
issue that users requested
or suggested, we wrote an
email to thank them and let
them know that their
issues have been fixed.
And people love this.
98% of our users who
received our email
would like to continue
to receive communication
like this.
It really showed that to
your users that you listened,
that you care, and that
they have been heard.
JONAH JONES: OK.
So back to the
original question.
How can you design your
apps for a billion people?
You think big, you
question everything,
and you listen to your users.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
ANNETTE LEONG: Thank you.
JONAH JONES: And we've got 17
minutes left for questions.
So if you've got any questions,
there's a couple of mics there.
And we'll be very
happy to answer them.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Thank you for the talk.
And also thank you for
redesigning Google Maps.
I think it's fantastic.
I had exactly the Pegman issue
when Google Maps was resigned.
As a UX guy, I was like,
it felt like a real misstep
for the design.
And when I eventually found
him down in the bottom corner
there, I was a
little bit confused
as to why you guys moved
like from a purely UI design
perspective.
Why he's down there with the
settings and also the tour.
But there are also some
options at the top right
and you can also do stuff
in the top left corner.
And there's also Street View in
the bottom left corner as well.
It just seemed to me to
not follow a hierarchy,
or like a functional hierarchy.
So can you talk
a bit about that?
JONAH JONES: Sure.
I mean the original thinking
behind taking away Pegman
actually was if you're going to
redesign a product like Google
Maps, there's like
thousands of features.
And we had to be
really, really bold.
And we wanted to see how much
we could take away and get away
with.
And like 90% of the
stuff we took away,
we got away with, which is good.
So you managed to
simplify, but we always
knew there was going
to be somethings
that we had to bring back.
And the Pegman was one of them.
And it was because of these two
mental models that people had.
A bit of insight is
that conceptually we'd
always thought of Pegman as the
deepest zoom of Google Maps.
And there used to be
this behavior that you'd
zoom in, zoom in,
and then suddenly
you'd hit Street View.
And that was why
Pegman used to be
on top of the zoom
slider over there.
But we would constantly see
people zooming in and then
accidentally getting into
Street View, and like--
and then coming back out again.
So it turns out that
it didn't really
make sense, conceptually, to
our users to have it that way.
And that's why when we
brought the Pegman back,
we brought him back
in the imagery area
down on the bottom right.
Because that's where you summon
all of the other imagery.
If you pull that up, that's
where the Street Views live,
that's where the panorama
photos live and everything else.
So it felt like that was
Pegman's natural home,
even though it was a
different place than where
he'd originally been living.
So that's why we put him there.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
When do you make the decision
to do such a large redesign?
I mean for applications with
so many users and things
like that, at what point
do you stop saying, oh we
should do that.
And say all right,
we're starting now.
JONAH JONES: We'd
kind of reached-
I alluded to this
at the beginning,
but we kind of reached the stage
where most people kind of felt
like they were happy
with Google Maps.
And that was fine.
But we realized that
first of all, there
was a big opportunity cost.
Because it wasn't
doing all these things
we wanted it to do.
But second of all, it was
kind of running out of space,
adding all these new features.
And we were adding features.
And all the discussions were
always around discoverability,
because everyone wants their
feature to be big and bold.
But it means all the other
ones can't be discovered.
And so we were basically
running out of space
to fit new features.
So we wanted to rethink it
and simplify it and also
build a frameworks to let us
add more and more new stuff
in a contextual way.
So it was kind of like
50% necessity, just
looking into the future
of where we were going.
And 50% that we wanted
to try something new.
And as we mentioned
before, just kind
of redefine expectations of what
Maps would be, rather than just
keep plodding away and adding
features to the same thing.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I notice now when
you search for cities,
you get a nice city border.
But when you zoom in enough to
figure out whether something's
in one city or the
other, it disappears.
And so there's this frustration
of zooming in enough
to see what you're looking for,
and then you lose your border.
I wonder if you could
explain the rationale for why
those disappear.
JONAH JONES: We actually
have quite a lot
of heated arguments about
this internally as well.
Because it turns out that when
people are searching for a city
or anything, like a
neighborhood or a zip code
or any of this stuff, you
might want different things.
Like some people are really
interested in the exact border
of the city.
In which case maybe we
should really highlight that,
get rid of everything else.
Just show all these stats
about the city and everything.
But then some other
people, maybe they just
want to send to
the viewport there.
Then in that case,
you don't want
to draw too much
visual attention to it.
And you want to show
the context too.
So we try to achieve a balance
between highlighting the thing
that you've searched for,
but not in such a way
that it's at the detriment
of anything else.
So it's just about trying to
balance what everybody wants.
And you'll probably see this
has changed in the past,
you'll probably see
it change again,
as we're trying to tweak
this to best answer
all of our users needs.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm wondering if you
have plans to include
the embed code
somewhere in the new UI?
Because I can't find it.
And I always have to switch
back to Classic Maps to get it.
JONAH JONES: I believe the
embed code is down in the--
ANNETTE LEONG: Yeah, so it
is actually in the Gear menu.
It's not the most
intuitive way at all.
We're still looking into
finding a better place for that.
If you click into
the Gear menu, you
should be able to see
share and embed map.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I have a question
about 3D buildings
and mapping and the
3D new imagery system.
You've just abrogated
it last year.
And just-- there were users who
were able to build and upload
by those [INAUDIBLE] using
SketchUp, using Building Maker.
And it seems maybe two
or three months ago, they
were not able to just upload
everything, because it
was canceled.
And there were more
than 10,000 modelers.
They had made millions of
buildings since you started.
And why did you decide
to cancel this project,
and what's the main reason?
JONAH JONES: So I'm
probably not the best person
to talk about this.
But I can give you like a
more of a design perspective.
My understanding
on this basically
is that we try to
kind of automatically
generate a lot of the
3D buildings we have
as we've been flying over cities
and stuff and building them up.
And we do have some
amount of buildings
that have been
specifically hand-modeled.
But I'm not 100% sure
on the exact policies
of what gets included
and what not.
So if you follow out
with me afterwards,
we can follow up
with [INAUDIBLE].
And he'll be able to
answer those questions.
So come and chat
to us afterwards
and I'll give you more detail.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was just curious.
To what degree was
the redesign informed
by the needs of low-end mobile
users versus desktop users?
JONAH JONES: So that's a
really interesting question.
So the vision of the future
of Google Maps that we talked
about was very, very
platform agnostic.
It was about this thing
that's personalized to you.
It's showing the data
that you care about.
It can dynamically change
for every single place.
And we wanted to achieve
this on all platforms.
And what you saw was that I
guess the first hint of that
was with the new iOS app that
we built with the new design
language.
And then a lot of the new
functionality and concepts
came into the desktop version.
And now they're starting
to find their way back
into the mobile version as well.
So all of the platforms
are kind of-- they're
almost like in a race.
Some are readier
earlier than others.
But we're all heading
toward this unified future.
And low-end devices are
going to be very much
an important part
of that as well.
It's not something that we've
been focusing heavily on
to begin with, but
definitely we're
going to be focusing very
much on speed and devices
with low connectivity and low
CPU and that kind of thing.
It's really important to
get those things working,
especially with the
Android 1 phones coming out
and everything.
Actually, I haven't
tried one of those yet,
but I'm really curious
to see how it works.
AUDIENCE: More generally,
about the process.
When you do decide
to do a redesign,
the three lessons are
sort of like three steps.
Is there a particular order
that you guys followed?
Did you listen to
users first, or did you
try to think big on your own?
Or is it all at the same time?
JONAH JONES: It's kind of all
at the same time, actually.
Because the benefit we had
of working on this product
for seven years, is that we've
run repeated usability studies.
We're getting
feedback all the time.
So we know what our
users' pain points are.
And we know what
areas of the products
are being underutilized.
So we knew, for example, that
we had all this great imagery,
and people weren't finding it.
So some of them are
explicit issues.
And other things are
just opportunity areas.
So we kind of just have
this idea of oh man,
this could be so much better.
So that was just
informing things.
And then obviously, if you
want to change something and do
something audacious, you've
got to question everything.
You've got to think big.
It's all kind of
part and parcel.
It's not really a step
one, two, three thing.
ANNETTE LEONG: Similarly,
like when you build a product,
you want to focus on
a few key use cases.
And then constantly,
you're looking back
at what you designed to see
if you are matching those use
cases.
And each time you
are not, then you
go back to the sketching board,
or talk to the researchers
how we can improve
the products further.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was hoping you could share
a little more about how
you conduct the user research.
Both before, during,
and after this process
for around the world.
It seems like a pretty
difficult problem.
I'm wondering what
the main steps were.
JONAH JONES: I wish we
had a researcher with us
to talk about this.
But we basically run a variety
of different research studies.
We can do super small scale
stuff, even within the company,
where you just go into a
cafe, and you get someone
to click on stuff.
We can bring people in and
have them test things out.
We can go to people's
homes and see
how they use things
in the real life.
There's diary
studies, where you can
get people to document
the things that they need
every day, and
what they're using.
And that can be across
different products.
Obviously, there's the feedback
that you get from users
when you get to send feedback
from within the product.
You can look at the metrics.
You can see what's getting
clicked and what isn't.
So we kind of used like a
dozen or so different ways
of getting this,
because they're all
flawed in their
own different ways,
so you're trying
to get around it.
AUDIENCE: And is it something
that if you look at that data
and say it's not
really making sense
for a particular
region of the world.
You'll go out there and
really attentively study that.
JONAH JONES: You
can certainly notice
that there are regional
differences in how people use
things, the kind of things
that they search for,
the kind of things
that they need.
And of course the data is
very different as well.
The data in the
Bay Area is great.
You go somewhere else, maybe
the data is a lot lower quality.
So things vary a lot.
It's really interesting.
ANNETTE LEONG: And sometimes
when you design a feature,
you may need multiple rounds of
research and usability testing
for that.
And then we had a long period
of time with internal dogfood,
where we collected a lot of
feedback from internal users.
So we actually
during that round we
made the feedback
button super prominent.
And people wherever they use
and run into any problem,
they can just click
there and that
would allow them to easily
file a request or bug.
JONAH JONES: It's also
worth pointing out
that we're a very diverse team.
Like you can hear that neither
of us are American here.
We have teams all
over the world.
And so I think
that actually helps
in bringing a very
global perspective
in building a product like this.
That we're not all just
focused on one place.
We've got people from
different point of views.
That helps too.
AUDIENCE: That was my
additional question.
Sorry for interrupting.
But I wanted to know how
localized the maps are.
And how different they are
in Asian countries, or let's
say in the Middle East.
JONAH JONES: So
we try and achieve
a balance between localization
where it makes sense,
because we want people
to feel familiar.
But we also want Google Maps
to be a consistent experience,
so that you recognize
it as you travel around.
So you'll see some
elements of the design,
like we have localized public
transit icons, for example.
But the things like-- what else
was a good example-- things
like restaurant
icons or something
like that are kind of
the same everywhere.
So we try and achieve a
balance of localization
where it makes sense
to be different.
But otherwise we try and
have a consistent style
so that everyone can predict
how to use the product.
ANNETTE LEONG: And
in terms of the UI,
we also created
the framework that
supports multiple languages.
Like some language like you
have to read from right to left.
So we had to make sure
that the framework could
allow a format like that.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering
if you could talk more
about the differences between
the mobile app versus the web
UI, which you were
showcasing more in this talk.
In particular, I run a UX
design agency in our office.
We were talking about
how much we really
enjoy the updates
in the web app.
And in the mobile
UI, we kept getting
lost in how you even start
a navigation session.
And it looked like
something's transferred well,
and other things didn't.
And maybe somethings
you're working on.
So I was just wondering if you
could shed more light on that.
JONAH JONES: I would
characterize that
as saying that we have
this vision of the future.
And then the mobile and
the desktop versions
were being developed
concurrently.
And so they're almost
like slightly different
interpretations of
that same future.
So the teams are sitting
right next to each other.
So the desktop team
were borrowing ideas
from the mobile
team and vice versa.
So it's mostly the same.
There are some things that
are deliberately different.
There are a few things that
are kind of unintentionally
different, that we want to fix.
But I think gradually
you're going
to see these things
converging increasingly.
And especially with the
new material design staff.
We really want to have
an experience where
it's very, very consistent as
you go from desktop to tablet
to mobile to watch
to Glass, whatever.
AUDIENCE: So for new features
like highlighting roads
next to points of
interest, are there
any plans to make those
accessible via the API
or any of the new features that
you guys talked about today?
JONAH JONES: That's a
really good question.
They do show up
on the API embed.
Follow up with us afterwards.
We've got the API guy here so
we can find out more about that.
I believe that's everything.
So thanks everyone
for your time.
ANNETTE LEONG: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]